well listen no matter what brad has to
say or what language he says it in there
is one person who wants them and that is
James Corden listen what he told our
Carly Steele I really would love to film
something with Brad Pitt not couple just
something fun I just dig him I think
he's funny
so do we James and speaking of dream
guests a-courtin was just spotted Friday
carpel in it with Bruno Mars
congratulations when you talk to us you
said he was your dream God's dream pile
up for namaz bruno mars bruno mars and
now you've done it
he didn't let me down in any way it's
the most fun I've had in the car I've
never had that much fun at work ever in
my life really yeah because he's just
got the songs in the funk and it's pruno
we spoke to James has he helped host
LA's air B&B open Festival this weekend
and coming up he's got a Christmas
karaoke with Mariah Carey
did you love that of course yeah there's
some treats installed but next up is
Thanksgiving I know you're British but
if you picked up some Thanksgiving truck
like well it just feels like it's just
Christmas without the presence you know
a huge roast turkey and then a month
wait I'm gonna do this all again with
the same people you've completely messed
up do it in May nothing's happening in
May